yeah Nick you saw a little game called
uncharted that's right I'm sorry guys
excuse me sorry yeah well you guys all
right you guys made sunset overdrive
sorry okay excuse look at y'all look at
the beard I got a cool distinguished
beer we're gonna talk to somebody who
didn't turn their back on PlayStation
all right I'm gonna talk about uncharted
Naughty Dog you might have heard of them
Neil druckmann Bruce Straley artists so
Greg when I was hanging out of my man
Cisco yes yeah we sent him to go see the
extended demo yeah saw two today he said
and although the other one yeah he said
and I quote Greg's gonna love this yeah
he know what he well wasn't awesome it
was awesome yeah it was one of those
were awesome right as we pull up into
the building right dr. white house style
building right so you were the demo from
the PlayStation demo was simple where
they were demo from the PlayStation
rotation okay yeah yeah you shut you
make throws the hook up and he swings it
along he dodges around the thing is it's
going hey Chloe hey Dad how are you good
Anna are you really all right you go
away now don't have time for these fan
girls oh my god all the time wherever I
go I never get it though I got a fan
boys fine sorry anyways you slam through
the thing and it keeps going and get
drug through the mud your mates getting
caked in mud right some he's pulling
himself up he's getting knocked into
things that should kill him and break
his arms but I don't today the game huh
to video game right crawls up the thing
gets into the back of a truck the truck
starts falling party shooting people
they're blowing up all sorts of Hell's
are going on he's still caked in mud so
super cool then he jumps on he gets in
this Jeep he gets into the front of the
GP takes over the Jeep he's driving
catches up to his brother Sam played by
Troy Baker they're going to sams on the
motorcycle like this Nate's in the car
like this it seems like all right jump
they both it was really cute thing they
both go jump on and like to each other
yeah like 10 I gotta design they start
arguing about who should jump on whose
car right and then I Sam goes look out
and stops and Nate gets t-boned by a big
old trial charged with Jason think flips
over and lands you know wrong side
wheels up in the air Nate's pinned
beneath the seats you push the seats off
then it start sparking a fire kicks off
now all of this is shot from like the
the waist up on you got his back up go
on get ready camera guy yeah Aaron you
got this you got this so like it's like
this like basically it's like this but
probably tighter like tighter here go
little tight on it all like we go right
here there you go do i do what do I owe
and then like the fire starts and he
starts he pushes up the thing and he
starts doing this number you ever do
this number yeah but he can't get a bud
and then there's fire going the right
air reaches up with really dramatic then
he grabs this thing up here to see me
pulls himself out like this one arm
below then he pushes the thing open and
there's two guys over there you were
you're gonna play these two guys okay
two guys over there and they go there's
no way there's no way somebody could
survive that and he pushes this thing
open and then these live and then he
starts shooting and make it shot a
couple times but then he dies first then
that guy dies next right then Sam pulls
up and get some Nate gets on the bike
and the bikes going and they're racing
away and then of course that big truck
from the demo 30 seconds they're either
they're doing this now so now you're the
truck everybody and I'm Nate and I'm
doing this since boom boom boom and the
cameras up here we will boom and
eventually blow that thing up and it
tumbles forward and they just dodge it
and then they have this like mom I was
like all right and then they drive home
to the hotel and they get a hotel and
they walk in the hotel and Nate's all
like we found the [ __ ] city of pirate
treasure that part I already forgot a
libertarian he opens it up in these
segments he walks in the room and he
looks over there any turns the corner
he's like a-ha oh [ __ ] and it's Elena
Elena's back dog back to the cam right
on it Elena goes how's the Malaysian
how's the job going to keep it locked
here seems like you're a hair off course
gamespot cross kind of funny at e3 2015
you